as if you look at some of my posts like
you know I make the mistake of not
reading who that post was made from how
do you say like the super liberals of
America and like yeah young tarnish
they're called yes all right so this is
the first year actually at Lauder with
credit we've we've wanted to do this a
few times where we've broadcast change
my mind segments we've had people come
on sometimes they've been very civil
sometimes they've been very hostile and
this next guest actually was on the most
recent changed my mind it guy I think
something like 200 no not 200 2.5
million places some 3 million place
somewhere around that and there was a
very passionate response and then she
did actually reach out to me on Twitter
to talk about her experience with
changement mine and I asked her
subsequently I said hey would you be
willing to come on the show and even
though we disagreed on some fundamental
issues nameless was a pro-life segment
she is she's here thank you so much for
being back here how are you I'm pretty
good it's been it's been a really
whirlwind of an experience I guess you
could say what I want to get to that in
a second first off I did want to thank
you because I I found out after the fact
that when we were running this change my
mind we'd prepared it and it was
uploaded that you had reached out to
some some people I guess through the
website who it wasn't me but I heard
after the fact that you asked us if we
could either remove it or I don't know
if it was blur your face and at that
point it was too late and I will tell
you this we've had those requests before
it we don't usually acquiesce because
then we never have any content out there
but once the video went up you didn't
pull it down and people have done that
in the past where we've had to re-upload
the video and fight through the YouTube
system so I appreciate that I know this
was probably a bigger platform than you
would anticipated but I appreciate you
not using the powers of censorship that
be to just get it removed yeah
essentially when I first sent those
videos I guess what really was or not
the video I'm sorry the email contacting
your team about it was because I guess I
was more in fear of maybe some of the
ramifications that my
occur in my life because I let myself
get personal and I usually don't do that
I'd read Freud really tried not to and I
guess it just runs such a strong chord
with me my emotions kind of came over me
and I you know at first I saw it is like
oh my god like everyone knows crap what
is everyone gonna think and then came to
light some of the issues that I've I've
dealt with which is depression and
anxiety and mental health because as you
know putting yourself in the spotlight
especially it's it's jarring in a sense
it is very it is very jarring and I
think that you did get personal but I
think you handled yourself very well and
again this is not even to speak of our
disagreements I think that's why people
had a very passionate response and I
know you said it's been a whirlwind what
would you say the overall response has
been because I've tried to direct my
fans my followers to be respectful and
and I've seen that in my experience from
my point of view be the majority of it
has that been the case it really depends
on what platform you look at what social
media you're looking at because when I
contacted you I made it I made a Twitter
I'd never really had a Twitter so I was
like okay well maybe if I just kind of
get ahead of it and say my small little
piece that I can and the little amount
of words that Twitter allows you
maybe it'll kind of help me a little I
guess
and Twitter was very positive mm-hmm I
had a couple sour apples you know nobody
that I can't handle something that I
expected however I did feel more
judgment on I guess YouTube and Facebook
um I can understand people don't agree
with what I did and some of the points
that I did bring up and having done more
research it
in itself actually did impact my
perspective of the entire conversation
and how well innocence I gathered that
what people had assumed of me was that I
did not regret my decision that I was
using it as contraceptive and that you
know I was this bad person overall
because I was wrong in my form of
justification
however oh my god I just went like oh
you just you just look blank oh I sorry
I thought the video went blank and in
which case not such a bad thing if you
can't see me know believe that this
happens this is my worst fear and it
happens to me all the time where I just
have mental band-aids where I go I go
another direction and as a comedian I
have the luxury of just going a
completely disconnected direction but
did you find did you find your spot
there now we were talking how it change
your perspective that you said some
people thought you were a bad person
yes yes it made me realize that yes you
know I I do regret the decision it's you
know personally I didn't get to say this
it's not something I would do again you
know I didn't get the chance to say that
I felt as though I squandered my
opportunity in what you would call
motherhood and you know I had felt
justified and what I had done but having
the conversation kind of made me
question my motives um question
did I actually you know take advantage
of all the opportunities that were
available but it even also made me want
to ask myself you know why like why
other women feel the way that I feel as
well you know what are those external
forces that guided my decision and how
many people feel that same way so well
you know yeah I I agree it was it's not
very
morale at all it it's it's very hard
would you are you surprised at all this
is this is very surprising to me to hear
you say this and I really do appreciate
it and let me say this this is kind of
the purpose of the whole change my mind
segment it started with me saying gosh
you know I kept getting these requests
to do cable news and sky and all the
stuff and I would do it every now and
then and it's kind of you know you go
there and people have their talking
points or you have one really good
argument and it goes viral but I said
you know the kinds of conversations that
we have around the fireplace or at the
bar at the pub or you know at the cigar
launch these are the kinds of
conversations that I really would love
to have on air but of course we've been
told no one wants to watch that and so
the approach is not one designed to be
caustic but designed to get people to
rationalize their own positions and and
see why they believe what they believe
and so what you're sort of explaining
here is the intended goal of the segment
but we often don't get to follow up with
people and so we kind of it goes out
kind of into the ether and we hope that
it works yeah but at least you know it
does work and you know I I hope other
women who have been in my position you
know I just want you to know don't
question your self-worth because we're
all human I'm still young I'm still
learning and what we do is we we ask
those important questions and the people
who are answering those questions
remember not to get heated because if
this was your own daughter you know you
can try and raise them the way that you
would want them to live but you can't
speak for their actions and you don't
know what mistakes they're going to make
but at the end of the day you know my
mom said something important she said
she's still gonna love me and she's
still gonna love me no matter what no
matter what anybody says or what I've
done and that actually was a that was
that was a step up because I had never
even disclosed this to any but anybody
besides my closest friends and if
there's only a very handful and I had
had conversations before with people but
I did remove my comments because I felt
as though I was getting more you know
personal and you know why why should I
feel that way you know why should I feel
as though I have to censor myself for
you to spare the argument and to help
you have that validation because you
need my perspective right here for your
point and well I think the perspective
here sort of you're you're looking back
my your retroactive perspective is also
helpful because you said you know listen
I think people maybe didn't realize that
that I'm not necessarily happy with
decision or you just I want to make sure
I don't misconstrue what you've said you
just used the word mistake does that
mean that you feel as though maybe some
of your decisions if you could go back
you would consider the mistakes or you
would you would redo them if you could
in this sense I don't like to I don't I
don't like to think of it as if I could
go back I would change what I did
because you know that's something that
is a little more detrimental especially
when you're dealing with depression
because a lot of times you're
questioning yourself were if you're
questioning what you've done and in
order to accept it and to guide it as
acceptance it's not necessarily you need
to go back like you can say you regret
it
yes you can say it's a mistake but I
can't say that I would go back and
change it because it happened right
that's a healthy perspective um you know
you said you feel as though you've
you've squandered your your opportunity
or chance for motherhood okay that's
that's not the case and now I would say
I'm not a doctor here but I would say
that's false guilt you have a whole life
ahead of you when you seem like someone
who wants to do the right thing seem
like someone has a level head in their
shoulders and listen depression anxiety
notwithstanding I've struggled with this
myself I've talked about it you
certainly will have that opportunity
many times over in your life so I would
hate for you to feel that way about it
or in any way for me to have made you
feel that way about it because that's
not my intent no I know I think I think
squandered was kind of like in the way
that I was using it was just kind of
saying like I had a chance and I'll have
more chances but I'm going through I'm
going to live with it for the rest of my
life and hopefully it can guide me to
make better decisions later on but I
also want you know other women to
realize if you are in this position and
you're you're making this decision every
everybody has their own accepts their
own circumstances that they're living by
can I ask you something because you
mentioned that you know was maybe going
for you know you were you used the word
regret or you said you weren't
necessarily happy with the decision but
obviously we don't want to wallow and
kind of regret and like you said past
mistakes but moving forward yeah let me
ask you this um would you say or would
it be fair to state that at the time
that you made that decision maybe there
weren't a lot of people sort of
providing this opposing perspective like
we did on the change my mind segment
where if you were to tell other young
women today that maybe it's a decision
that has more severe ramifications than
they know going into it and it should be
considered more carefully well whenever
it comes to you know these women making
this decision I mean I had I had some of
I had some some conversations with
people and I think what initially how
did like did not encouraged me to want
to reach out to you know even my mom or
even family is because I know that
they're conservative and I was I was
concerned with their judgment and I
think women today they're under this you
know pressure of you know trying to
obtain I guess
perfection and like you know or seeming
perfect and I just felt as though like
well you know I don't want anybody to
ridicule me and I I guess it was it was
that fear of being ridiculed
that kind of led me to not want to seek
those options and or like those kinds of
discussions because you know the one
person that I respect you know in this
not I respect a lot of people but the
person that whose judgment matters most
to me as my mother and it was the fear
of disappointing her and then afterwards
I realized it was still the fear of
disappointing her by her knowing about
it
yeah and then it turns out she's not
disappointed mmm if anything she feels
guilt because she felt as though she
could not she did not communicate
successfully that I had that support
system and I think it's important to sit
down with your daughters and you need to
tell them like look I understand you're
at this age and you're going to start
doing these things but you also need to
realize that no matter what happens you
have a support system and you know
that's kind of really conversations that
we didn't have like you know we never
thought that was gonna be an issue for
us I think that's a good point um and
I've talked about this in the show I
think we're a lot of Christian
conservatives missed the boat a little
bit is assuming that their kids aren't
going to make mistakes and so they don't
necessarily have I forgive the term you
but a plan B in other words to discuss
what their kids listen if you do make a
mistake we are here and and not that
this is necessarily a mistake meaning
you know a child is not a mistake but
I'm saying let's say they assume that
their kids aren't necessarily sexually
active and or they're being responsible
that not all kids are all the time in
adults when they're definitely not right
exactly and let me ask you this yes I
appreciate you saying that because we
have a lot of college students who
approach the change my mind
who do not think that way they think I'm
gonna school this guy and let him know
how the real world works because they've
done two years of philosophy and it
doesn't necessarily turn out that way
let me ask you to go back to that do you
think that if your mother or your family
would have communicated more so to you
you know the other options when you were
pregnant that there was a strong support
structure and they would be there for
for you no matter what or do you think
that at least if you understood that to
be the case that maybe you maybe you
would have made a different which wasn't
a different path I think it would have
it would have impacted it um it would
have allowed me to think a little bit
harder I kind of just like went in
thinking that I was alone in thinking
that okay well as a single mother what
am I gonna do what am I gonna get a job
you know and you know it's literally
like putting a pause on your life and
you know that's a big deal
it's not like getting dumped and like oh
there's no hope no that's it's not the
case it's it's considering like can I
provide the quality of life to this
child the quality that I believe it
deserves and you know at the time I was
not confident in myself and doing that
so and you didn't like I said you didn't
believe you had a support structure in
place and this is a huge problem that I
have with places like Planned Parenthood
in abortion clinics and we don't need to
get into your personal story but I'm
willing to bet my bottom dollar that
they did not go out of their way to show
you the support systems that are out
there and the services that exist should
you want to have this child be a mother
or put the child up for adoption you
know there are a lot of crisis pregnancy
centers a lot of non abortive centers
that they do provide that they do direct
people toward an iing services they do
help with placing single mothers in job
scenarios or actually helping them
complete education planned parent and a
lot of these abortion clinics are
actually precluded from doing that and
recently when we did a video in Colorado
they actually were passing out pamphlets
saying there are these people who are
frauds who say they want to help you
with your reproductive options but they
just don't want you to get an abortion
and I'm going hold on a second if they
are offering support with
the other op it may not be the option
that you agree with but it seems to me
that it would behoove women to really
know of all the options available and
almost support that is there for them to
not feel it sounds like you felt a
little bit trapped kind of in this
decision you had to make not necessarily
trapped cuz I can say I went in it you
know under the circumstances and from
what I had believed in the
justifications that I was under at the
time you know I went in there fully
confident knowing this is what I wanted
to do and even throughout I was very
shake I was shaken I was alone I was I
was really in turmoil but but you you do
have a point the other options were not
it was more in passing you could say
they were available it was there you you
talked to someone beforehand but you
know it's it you I think you mean
they're not equipped to offer you with
those options they're not they're not
we've talked about that I don't think
they're professionally trained um to the
level that we we should be paying
attention to cuz you know like I said I
cannot definitively speak for anyone so
I still believe it is a choice but I do
not believe that it is you know moral I
don't think that like I think it should
be something very well thought through
well the reason I bring that up is
because these people are trained in
upselling you to the abortion because
that's their main profit driver at these
clinics for example at Planned
Parenthood they are trained in
presenting you with the option of
abortion they are qualified to direct
you toward abortion they are not trained
nor qualified to direct you toward other
options and that's what I find so
disconcerting that they they often can
make women feel trapped by going yeah
well here's here's abortion this is what
it'll be this what the procedure is like
this is what the post-op is like and if
you want to have the baby but you know
you want to put up for definite here's a
pamphlet at the front door and that's
not really empowering women
ah the wife who who's worked at these
centers quite a bit we just did a video
with Abby Johnson who was a worker at
Planet parrot and they've talked about
how a lot of not only the women but the
workers feel trapped you said kind of
this is interesting to me he said your
justifications that you believed at the
time and they've changed a little bit
have they changed because of our
conversation that changed my mind or
have they changed if they have changed
how they changed at all it in the sense
it's changed towards somewhat more
understanding whenever we were talking
about the socio-economic levels or those
external pressures that exist but in the
sense of changing the justification I
don't feel as though I was a hundred
percent justified I feel as though you
know I should have put some more
consideration into it I think you know
that I myself am going to continue to
grow on this but it's it's less solid
than it was when I first thought sure
about it when I was talking to you so
you did I'm even the ground a little bit
lot well my goal was not to cause a
tectonic shift or an earthquake at all
it's just just to make sure no no and I
and I don't I don't expect to you know
you don't do that what it's healthy it's
healthy to challenge me and my
perspectives because not right I'm 23
years old I had no way less than someone
who's been on this earth for even 30 40
50 and so on you know so much more than
me of so much more life experience and I
think that's why people my age we should
be willing to have these top
conversations not only with each other
but with older with you know the older
generations and I think vice versa I
wouldn't place myself in older
generations what I see
we could have been in school at the same
time no no I I agree with you and I find
it true that you say that because here's
the thing I don't necessarily I don't
get this from life experience I think
that these segments come from simply
examining the why you know we talked
about the Socratic method quite a bit
which by the way have you this is not a
trick question
have you been taught the Socratic method
in college at all a lot of kids don't
they're never taught the Socratic method
which is just the the it's just the
method it's the approach of
rationalizing your position in examining
ok why do I believe this what is a
justification for this belief and that's
been replaced with identity politics in
a lot of ways I think a lot of this
information comes from and I learned
with the audience and I learned with you
and we sit down and talk because you can
tell the audience nothing up my sleeve I
had no idea what you were going to say
no idea what your position was going to
be I appreciate your boldness but do you
think that the fact that this is so
novel the whole change my mind on
college campus do you think that's
indicative of dialogue being shut down
before something like this can take
place because what we did is what should
be happening in every single classroom
every hour of the day on college campus
and it doesn't seem like that's the case
a lot of times I mean whenever you're in
a college course a lot of times I feel
like unless you're really interested in
that topic people are not paying
attention and it also depends on the
professor I mean I've had so the
Socratic method what you brought up
that's actually something I have been
using um it just wasn't really sure what
the definition was for a second but
because I'm I am minoring in
anthropology I've taken sociology
psychology because there's some of the
most phenomenal classes you can take
if taught by a phenomenal professor
otherwise a complete crap yeah yeah I'm
I can't speak for everyone but I know
that in the classes that I've taken man
they will really make you question
a lot of you know your ideas and I will
say that sorry he was asking me to
download something okay
so it's probably a virus I wouldn't I'd
never accept downloading unless you know
exactly what it is but continue yeah but
I will say you know I've had those
professors professors that will you know
there are very enlightening because
they're willing to have these kinds of
conversations and I've witnessed certain
ideas being challenged either on the
progressive or more conservative side it
doesn't matter and that's without any
bias either and I think that's what's
missing is the lack of bias whenever
you're trying to teach your students how
to communicate and validate their ideas
is that there is a lack of bias like
there needs to be a lack of bias I don't
know that I agree I think it just needs
to be in genuine search of the truth for
example I mean I'm biased I'm very open
about it you know when you sat down I
would like to think that it's it's a
positive example of how we didn't really
find common ground but we can still be
civil a lot of times people go oh most
people just we need to come to the
middle I go in law second there's right
and there's wrong and sometimes the
right thing to do is not in the middle
that's my view and that's my view on
abortion and I felt as though I was
pretty firm in expressing my views
without being a dick I it surprised me
like I'm serious congratulations like
you have really changed my mind when it
come to how like me some people can be
when it comes to be kind of topic you
assumed I was going to be a dick is that
what I hear yeah well I mean it's I mean
it's just the kind of same way that
people assume that I'm a hardcore
liberal and I just want everything like
I want to I don't I don't even know I
don't even know whatever these crazy
ideas kind of get it we catch ourselves
putting somebody in a certain stigma and
I think that's what we shouldn't do I
don't think we should pre conceived the
characteristics of somebody just because
they
place or they how do you like they place
themselves with a specific group right
now because you're conservative doesn't
mean that you're like this far-right
Nazi jerk
who's trying to eliminate all you know
I'm saying yeah well I would say those
are left us because they were socialists
the Nazis but that gets us to another
philosophic socialist so you know I
wouldn't put them once the right-wing
right a lot of liberal media does like
to use a lot of also conservative on
both ends I don't think well I've been
accused of that with this very so that's
actually something I wanted to okay
couple this is kind of a lightning round
then we'll get right back to the
conversation but first off yeah did I
edit you out of context in any way I
mean we changed that's one thing we
changed shots because of to me talking
them you talking well yeah because we
want to see her face and we want to see
my face for talking yeah but okay so you
at you out of out of context and yes and
you were there for a good portion of
that day I mean you saw most of these
conversations were pretty similar
outside of some of the screaming
protesters there were a couple of those
I think that's why I wanted to approach
you was because I felt like it wasn't
being properly repartee weren't you
weren't getting the real side of the
story you know and I think that's kind
of what encouraged me to come and talk
to you guys I was like some of these
things that these guys are saying
there's a really makes sense you know
considering like comparing a child to a
parasite like that's not the case well I
asked you this because we've been
accused of selectively editing people
who change my mind
or we've been accused of misleading
people and the reason we picked yours
was because a you were personal and
again I want to see what your opinion on
this is on this so people watching can
can kind of understand what happens
behind the scenes the reason we picked
yours first to run was because I thought
it was an authentic position where
neither one of us Miss characterized
each other there were some people who
sat down and just said now listen man
you're not gonna have anything that's
gonna you're not anything that's valid
because you're not a vegan and I was
gonna you know what this isn't something
to run because it's not going to be
productive the reason we picked yours
was because Frank
this kind of follow-up it was something
that I thought was was productive and I
thought there was a lot to take from it
so it seems to me as though okay you
would agree you weren't necessarily
taken out of context and what would you
say to people who say because I've been
banned from some campuses that I am a
right-wing Nazi extremist who simply
shows up and before the cameras roll
insult people looking to stir up a fight
and then let them roll I think that's
very ansari absurd because you were very
like in and out like you really didn't
give people time to hurt the time to
harass you and i think that's something
that's very good because you take what
people say with a grain of salt and like
i think people shouldn't banned these
conversations but they also shouldn't
allow themselves to get over emotional
you can get emotional true because you
can that emotion is linked to your
passion and then you must explain that
emotion as well as that passion but you
can't dismiss another boy yes because if
you have is just much freedom to speak
to that person then you must allow that
person the same freedom to speak to you
one of the rules that i've always lived
by his treat others the way you want to
be treated
i remember that from kindergarten pre-k
that was literally the words written on
the walls everywhere treat people the
way you want to be treated and i feel
like i lived by that um i do think he
did even though we disagree on like i
said on some of some of the issues i do
think that you were very respectful and
even even after you left and it got
pretty personal intensely personal you
were very respectful and i was very glad
to hear from you again that you were
willing to come on the show because we
have had people get really heated and
we've had people try to take some swats
and we've had people who've definitely
tried to ban us and so i do understand
that it's a luxury to not be banned in
this culture on college campus and we do
have to be careful and get in get out
keep her head down and then sometimes i
wish i would have known you were there
we would have showed up but that's kind
of the whole point because if you know
in advance then people start getting
their torches and pitchforks ready you
blindsided
let me tell you I was just going to
class I was a lecture like any other day
I almost didn't go to class that day
what I wouldn't admit that on air
because your professor now is watching
going and that's an F okay that's fair
but you know it's honoring to have an
opportunity like this to speak with
someone like you because like I said
before from the bottom of my heart
honestly I'd never watched any of your
videos I don't even know who you were I
call my brother my mother still thinks
that I just fool around in a podcast
yeah right yeah I called my brother and
I was like hey do you know steven
crowder is like I just talked to him in
here
flipped he was like what do you mean and
so he explained it she had me sent me
your videos I was like oh what have I
done like you're just like oh my God my
mom is gonna see this so and you know
while I was it was hard to watch the
video Oh bleep I don't watch them I
don't watch them because I can't watch
myself either so it's hard to watch
yourself on camera period don't don't
worry about that that's normal well in
like you know I'm well personally I have
you know I have certain things that I'm
insecure about like the with my
appearances and you know I finally broke
down and watched the video and I was
like mmmm
I could have made some better points or
I could have communicated that a lot
better but see if I wouldn't have done
that I wouldn't have been able to learn
from it um and I think that's what's I
think that's what's necessary people
shouldn't be banning you well I think
right I I don't think people should be
banning speakers who are actually far
more caustic than myself as long as
there's no incitement to violence and in
the goal with this yeah it's kind of
this is me just speaking down I'm on a
personal level it's kind of a struggle
because people think well you show up
and you don't let people know who you
are and your dick because you're
sandbagging but then if I show up and go
don't you know who I am you know so we
just actually set up and you seem like
you're posting right exactly and so
that's why I also try to never appeal to
the audience which I did one one time
and I remember because the audience was
really cheering and it was really loud
and I said you know I never want to do
that again that's why even if people who
agree with me shout somebody down I said
I don't want to do that this is really
just designed to be a conversation
between two people something that you
said that was interesting though I'd
like to go back to you said this these
sort of ill-conceived notions I guess
that you're a far left leaning sort of I
don't want to put words in your mouth
but I guess how would you describe your
your sort of political social worldview
honestly the way that I view politics is
whoever closely aligns with the policies
that I want to see enacted that's who I
vote for
I don't just vote you know democratic or
Republican I actually vote mixed I'm
very centered
I've never proclaimed a political party
to be my own sometimes if you look at
some of my posts like you know I make
the mistake of not reading who that post
was made from and it'll be like the
super art like how do you say like the
super liberals of America and like yeah
young terms they're called yes but yeah
like I'll go back and I'll remove a post
like a post that if I feel like that
page doesn't really align you know if I
don't catch it all the time sometimes
I'm just sharing just cuz I support the
video but really in my political views
I'm really Pro um how do you say I'm Pro
making America great again place livable
I guess a livable country just something
that we can all say that we're proud of
to help our community members help those
who are in need as in like if you're
having a really bad day and someone just
like holds the door open or you're
trying to get gas and you're counting
pennies and someone pays for your gas I
had
you sure I mean it's happened before but
let me tell you man those are just those
are the best moments yeah and I think
just living kind of by those rules of
just you know being kind and respectful
to others talking about personal
responsibility and personally doing the
right thing versus you know most kids in
college campus who believe it's the
government's job to be the arbiter of
all things sort of good the people are
the ones who decide who's in government
and the people who are in government
represent us and I think if we focus on
trying to be real politicians oh man I
just not bear the biggest fan of
politicians generally just because it's
hard to find that real person yeah try
to find ones who don't suck and that's
how you kind of end up with you know the
the Donald Trump's and the cortezes of
the world where listen most people going
yeah I think Donald Trump says some
things that are ridiculous sometimes
like he clearly said Tim Apple he didn't
say Tim Cook oh I don't know why he
would lie about that but you know what I
like that he pisses off these people who
are crazy
more than the other candidates so I like
him and then Cortes people can look at
her and go I mean she's barely walking
upright her statements are completely
unintelligible but we like now that she
pisses off the Donald Trump crowd and it
seems like that's what a lot of people
are voting for I do identify as
conservative I'm fine with that
generalization because it does encompass
most of my views your views yeah it
absolutely does yeah and I think it's a
cop-out when a lot of people say I'm not
saying that that you're copping out here
but a lot of people who clearly are
conservative or who clearly are liberal
go I don't like labels move on a second
do you support socialized health care
yes do you support free college for all
yes
do you support abortion up until birth
and potentially afterward yes do you
support a higher marginal tax rate yes
you're a socialist you're a liberal just
say so and then if I suffice it listen
are you pro-life yes okay
are you Pro fair tax flat tax yes are
you Pro limited constitutional
government yes you're a conservative now
I don't like labels I think labels are
necessary and that just like the
Constitution where it isn't James
Madison talked about this it is
necessary to then explain the context of
this writing for example to bear arms
your general welfare clause
it's perfectly natural to say I'm
conservative or I tend to be liberal but
I believe a B and C and yeah on college
campus would you say that a lot of kids
are afraid to just say I'm conservative
I don't really think that they're afraid
okay you got to remember you where am i
I'm in Texas that's true a lot we're
proud to be conservative not in college
campuses though the most aggressive
people yeah I mean we've had people run
up and scream in my face and every kid
specially in Austin oh my god yeah my
mom always says Austin is what she says
what she's like it's the People's
Republic of Austin I can't I can't
remember it it's actually really funny
my grandfather would say that if the if
God were to give Texas an enema he'd
stick the hose in Austin I think people
are actually relatively conservative
they just they they just want to smoke
Elan a pot so people think it's a very
liberal City and I will say that
surprised that's this perception in
Austin if you look they want their
business taxes low they still want to
benefit from the Texas economy they want
to happen they want to have their right
to own their guns they just want to
smoke pot and go some nuded hippie
Hollow that's a lot of people in Austin
but it surprised me that on campus
across all of Texas or Oklahoma or a lot
of conservative states once you get on
campus it still is an enclave of very
often one point of view expressed I mean
let me ask you this you saw obviously
some of the screaming protesters there
and it was balanced there were quite a
few people who were actually happy to
see this this approach and enjoy the
sort of change my mind segment but can
you think of any instant where there
were conservatives having that same kind
of visceral screeching reaction to a
liberal speaker on campus because I
cover news day in and day out I never
see it so it's not necessarily like they
were like screeching and awful but while
I was waiting before you you know and I
don't like I don't support anything like
the
the fella who was like interrupting you
that's not cool I'm gonna call me a Nazi
yeah but you know I'm one of those and
one of those is real supporting Nazis
here I watched some I couldn't even
finish watching it just because it
didn't make sense to me but I mean
beforehand like I think he felt like a
bombardment cuz I got was on the other
side I felt like it was almost invited
like there was like one side that I was
standing on but once I walked over to
the other side I kind of made a comment
and then I had three different guys
start you know kind of making their own
side comments and I guess you know they
weren't screaming they were they were
they were being very calm they were
actually very calm and I wish I could
have gotten to speak to them a little
bit more and at that time I was
realizing I was allowing myself to let
my emotions get in the way rather than
listen to what they were saying so
there's not always going to be that
screeching conservative or even liberal
but one of those liberals there's always
at every camp and there's always ones I
think it's far more rare to find the
screechy conservative because they just
want to let people speak but there's
always the yeah the leftist screaming
that we're not see because like I've
I've been like you ever drive some bass
some of those abortion clinics like
they'll scream some really really mean
stuff to you even if you're just like
there to get a pap smear like I hate
that word but that's just my male
privilege it's just a relapse it's like
it feels I feels like something that the
one would do with a bagel only you take
the bagel and go oh I'm never getting a
bagel here again but let me here's
actually final question on this you said
that you rethought ton of some of your
stances and in what you I guess sort of
the justifications for abortion we don't
need to get into that this doesn't need
to be an argument at all but um let me
ask you this the kind of approach that
was taken here would you say that it got
you to at least think more and consider
an opposing viewpoint more so than let's
say one of those people who just have a
poster with chopped up baby parts
yes definitely it will impact you a lot
more um and you know those same people
who are standing out there by the post I
kind of compare them to the same people
who have the an amenity of in the
internet you can say all you want about
how fat I am you can say that I'm a
murderer that I'm ill educated that I
don't know anything because I don't want
like I'm still learning and um I think
that at the end of the day you know if
you want to get your point across you
know respect and kindness is gonna get
way further you attract more bees with
honey than you do with vinegar so you
know promise I'm allergic to bees so
then it just ends up being the last
scene from my girl and no one likes that
it ends up being it ends up being
actually very tragic no I I agree with
you by the way there are plenty of
people who do you know stand outside of
abortion clinics who say hey listen we
can provide you with an ultrasound hey
listen we can provide you some you know
some access to services that could help
you with jobs but so I do want to make
sure that we differentiate between them
but yeah I I've been accused of not
being pro-life enough because I've said
listen man I don't think the chopped-up
baby parts outside of a town square
where people are even just having lunch
with their kids is yeah I don't think
it's appropriate and I'm as pro-life as
they come and be I don't think it's
effective so I've been accused by people
further on that side of you know denying
the truth and and I don't I probably
agree with all of their views on where
life begins I just don't agree what's
the method in trying to reach people
convey the message like right and you
know one of the things though that also
was resonating with me was the amount of
support and positivity that I also saw
and it it's really something to think
about for every million of positive
let's say comments for every million
positive comments that one harsh
negative comment
will completely outshine the rest it is
it'll ruin your day and that's something
that people need to remember while
you're typing up those words I want you
to think about saying those same words
to your daughter or to someone that you
love and could you ever say those words
and out loud to someone that you love
cuz if you can't maybe you should
rephrase yourself um even if you're okay
with saying those kinds of things I
think we should sit down and we should
talk to the counselor because some
issues I need to talk with a counselor
because the way my brother and I speak
to each other and people here in this is
just awful I thank god there's no
transcript
yeah we just rib each other well listen
first off is there is there anything
else that you would like to leave in
closing for people who are watching this
I will say this before you make any
statement I know that you said you were
really nervous and that this went out to
the world and it was a big platform
listen I think a lot of people obviously
disagree with you and I think
realistically there are a certain amount
of people who are going to have a
negative a negative impression of you
but I will say this being the first
person to do this and how you've handled
yourself today
there are far more people out there by
the way same people who still disagree
with your decision who have respect for
how you've conducted yourself and your
willingness to engage far more than
there are people who despise you so I
want you to know that regardless of the
comments you read so remember that when
you read a negative comment yeah but is
there anything that you would like to
leave people with in regards to how they
kind of perceive you well essentially if
you feel like you are questioning
yourself worth and you've gone through
the same thing you guys have my Twitter
handle you can feel real can you say it
again for it's gonna be Yara Murray
three that's Twitter your America yes I
am an artist so if you do want to check
out some of my art it's yaar emory one
two three on instagram but I want to
encourage women if you're questioning
yourself worth in your value please you
know you can reach out to me you can
talk to me I can't judge you obviously
and or you can reach
two ones close to you but don't do it
alone don't feel like you're alone
there's so many people out there and
like you said there's so many positive
people who may not agree with what I
said but they're still very positive and
they outshine a lot of the rest I am
going to continue to study hopefully I
can you know keep my career going I'm
still trying to figure out what I'm
trying to do with my life that's that's
normal for your age people don't know
it's terrible in Quebec where you
graduate high school I graduated a year
early I was 16 people graduate at 17 in
you basically have to know what you want
to do for the rest of your life by the
time you're 14 if you want to get into
advanced I imagine that figuring out
your life at 14 don't put pressure on
yourself for that I would say put
pressure on yourself to examine your
positions why why you believe what you
believe put pressure on yourself to do
the right thing but don't put pressure
on yourself to have life completely
figured out at this point
final question well final question and
then a statement if you could do it over
again would you would you still do the
change myself girls stop getting so
personal stop using I it's okay though I
appreciate how authentic you were and
you know what in party if ever you would
like to host an event or where you
interview me maybe at your campus and
talk about the fallout and your
experience we usually don't have a lot
of time to do this and we only visit two
campuses per year but because of the
respect you've shown you I would I would
love to do that with you at some point
as as a follow up I really appreciate
your taking the time yarrow thank you so
much okay if you like this video you
know you watch videos on YouTube but
fiber Jimmy Kimmel if I were Stephen
Colbert or Trevor Noah I would tell you
to subscribe but I have no corporate
overlords who demand that I do this
demeaning promo I do the demeaning promo
because I choose to subscribe or hit the
notification bell because I need you I
need
you please do it